right good afternoon everyone and
welcome to this meeting of cabinet uh
held today Monday the 3rd of October uh
do we have any apologies for absence on
we do we've got apologies from
councilors Barker and Parry
thank you do I have any disclosures or
interest in terms of items on the agenda
please
take that as a no minutes can I confirm
and sign the minutes of the meeting held
on the 5th of September
are there any comments on the minutes
I'll take that as a no so I will sign
the minutes after the meeting
so part A matters to be referred to
council non Part B massive decision by
cabinet and item four Deputy leader
Place portfolio over to you Mr Pemberton
thank you leader
thank you leader the first item
um
for decision by cabinet
is seeking agreements for formally
Consulting on amendments to part L of
the development requirements SPD and
approve the proposed the members to part
you of the development requirements SPD
in short the Cancer's decision to seek
to acquire public open space
particularly through development
necessitates the need to revisit our
existing spds as they relate to open
space the papers before you cabinet
seek to enable us to
um
amend part U and part l
and consult on those changes so that
those changes can be given life to I
have Matthew Neal with me not with me
per se but in the room who will take any
uh technical questions from members of
cabinet and or Observers
fine uh are there any questions or
points uh fine uh councilor Harvey then
councilor junid
can I let's turn to page 20 page eight
is a document
[Applause]
um paragraph four uh Under The Heading
reads all public open space will be
adopted by either a town or a parish
council
and my question is
should the word will
actually be May
um if if I pardon the pun May
um I understand that grammatically that
is more correct and also operationally
more correct in the sense that there may
be
resistance on some occasions from a
developer
to allow us to secure public open space
having said that I am Keen for us to set
out a position that our default as an
organization is that we will acquire
public open space the debacle of
privately managed public open space
is a disgrace and I think we should by
the use of the positive affirmation we
will
um
um put in the minds of future developers
that that's the expectation and if they
want to persuade us otherwise there's
going to be an extremely bar over which
to
get and I would not wish to dilute the
wording in any way that detracts from
that overarching policy objective even
though you know we recognize that
every so often we may have to rub back
from that but that will necessitate
a a really good evidence base and case
so to do
councilor Harvey the reason for for
raising that is that I'm aware in my
ward of Parish Council not willing to
take on an open space
the wording here seems to
um put town and Parish councils under an
obligation now I know from what you've
just said that's not what you mean what
you mean is that it's either town or
Parish Council in the first
to will I think the wording could be
amended to make that clearer
I think if there's no dilution of the
intention I'm quite happy for there to
be a further discussion with Matthew
Neal about the sort of my no shy of it
if you're comfortable with that
councilor Harvey
councilor junid and then councilor
kettle
um
that could be my apologies
um that the calculation doesn't allow
allow you to go off-site if you can't
provide the provision of public open
space within the development or
presumably if the Town Council or Parish
Council can't take on a site however
what I'm particularly wanting to ask
about is when I look through some of the
um the
papers later on on the committed and
uncommitted funds held by
stratford-on-avon District Council
there's at least three occasions when
off-site open space has been calculated
but it's not ending up going to what the
account what the developer or what the
planning originally specified which was
to provide open space
for the people of those or nearby to
that development it is in one case in
three cases it's for the Riverside
project for example which is you know
I'm no problem with it being delivered
what I'm just saying that
um I don't want to see this kind of
spread too far away from the original
intention or the original community
that the public open space is meant to
um serve so I'm just making that point
because I know that in speaking to the
um the resident social Association
Deputy chair and he did bring that up
thank you councilor do you need
counselor kettle
uh thank you Mr chairman yeah it goes
back to
um
paragraph four on page 20.
um there is I think uh and that I really
knows I like calculating things but I
think to duplicate then calculate twice
in the heading of paragraph four line
two
to maintain then calculate then
calculate can we take one of those out
um that's a minor Point uh are you
counselor Harvey in disguise
however
I would take issue with counselor
Harvey's earlier argument which you you
I think you expressed a far more robust
approach Council Pemberton which
um I absolutely support uh we have seen
time and time and time again uh open
space has been offered to Parish
councils at a commuted sum which is
worth probably a couple of weeks worth
of maintenance
um which is then they have not been able
to accept for their own Financial
property
only for the new residents that site
uh to pick up
um an unspecified and uncontrollable
cost for ongoing maintenance
so whilst I understand Council Harvey's
reticence to accept the word is it says
I would like to see it stay exact as it
is
um
I would also like just on the very last
second penultimate line of that
paragraph
I thought the communities some will be
an annual cost including inflation I
think we should have an annual cost
um including maintenance including
annual maintenance in our because
otherwise it doesn't specif it isn't
clear what you mean by annual cost
and what we want to see is a figure plus
the 10 plus the management fee plus 20
years we need we need that to be
absolutely clear so there can be no
argument and I know Mr Nash is with us
today he and I have on previous
occasions
tried really hard to get developers to
accept
a meant a reasonable estimate of a
maintenance cost they have just refused
so I think in this spt can we please
include at least the word maintenance
councilor Pemberton
I think once again if if members of
cabinet are happy for uh to defer to
myself as portfolio holder and the lead
officer to ensure because I know we we
reference standard rates and that's in
the context of standard rates around
maintenance if members of cabinet are
happy with the recommendation allowing
some really minor tweaking around
clarification and I think we can do that
rather than try and agree a a wording I
would just also make a very brief
comment about in relation to uh
councilor Junior's comment
um I mean clearly you start we start to
get into the individual cases you know
within the you know the sort of
committed and uncommitted Sons whereas
here we're talking about policy and
policy objectives I would just make the
comment that
we do need to be Innovative about
ensuring that
um the the public realm is enhanced by
public open space if there is a parish
or tank Council that won't take
something on perhaps as a community
interest or charity or can organization
that could do so in the example of a
site where I'd rather use it than lose
it and so things like
lifting funds to something like
Riverside achieve an overall objective
so I think in the round there I think
we're in the right place and hopefully
uh members of cabinet can support the
recommendations with that minor latitude
I've requested Mr Grafton I believe you
want to come in at this point
yeah just to pick up on the
recommendation if you read the
recommendation you'll find there are
actually two separate recommendations
one is a part about part U
which you've been asked to recommend
to full Council for approval
and the second part of the Clause is
around part l
um which you're being asked to formally
consult upon so I think there are two
there are two separate recommendations
there one about part U one apart part L
path L includes the reference to public
open space and may I suggest that if you
are minded to accept that part of the
recommendation then you can pick up the
wording as to whether it's will mail
whatever on the result of the
consultation process
thank you Mr Grafton councilor Cargill
thank you yes um as cancer June had
mentioned that I was County council at
the time when we were neither meeting
with the residence Association
um at the passengers to
can the city of their concerns about the
actual fleece called as they called it
and brought them into the council and
this is a positive resource I'm very
pleased about them thank you very much
indeed
um right there's just a couple of
comments which um perhaps some
clarification if I may on page
25 uh the document 13. we talk about two
things here first of all is communal
space
and a guideline of X meters per dwelling
Etc now
are we going to be four four forced into
the same situation of having to have a
management company look after that
because at the end of the day it's a
shared space it's shared through through
Flats Etc this is just a clarification
of his and to have and the other thing
was on the paragraph above that on the
public private distinction and picking
up Council pemberton's comments about
design distinctiveness Etc
um can we somehow make sure that
bin storage is not in the same area as
this because again this is for people's
Recreation and health and well-being we
don't want then storage in there and of
course we're talking about fairly
serious amounts of storage space on
blocks of flats Etc thank you noted
thank you in that case I see no more
members of cabinet wanting to make a
comment so
are we dealing just with the open space
or we're dealing with Section part U as
well
both
um
in which case
um on page 35 the section 106 liability
assessments section
um
what I would very much like to see here
is
um
if the developer is required to appoint
um
an ex an external expert
to carry out a viability assessment or
to report on viability assessment
that we see
the terms of reference
and not comfortable with those terms of
reference before that independent expert
is appointed
the reason I say that is
it is very easy to get a report saying
what you wanted to say if you tell the
report writer
um what you wanted to do
we need to have input into that and we
need to make sure we're quite
understanding exactly what you're saying
councilor Kettle uh Mr Grafton would you
care to comment
great
um I'm not an expert on viability
assessments but what I would say is that
if you have a third party who is
instructing their own experts
um then having
sight of their instructions and having
input into their instructions is not a
right of the council but will be subject
to separate negotiation and agreement
in the same way that if we instructed
and we sometimes have
um external bodies to conduct viability
assessments on the back of one that
we've received from the developer then
they would have no right as such to see
our instructions or or see the report
just to help you
counselor Kettle that in essence that
becomes a jointly instructed viability
assessment and the fundamental
underpinnings as I understand it are
that it is for the applicant to bring
forward
advice certain advice information in
support of any contention it makes in
respect of any element of a planning
application as the local planning
Authority it is entirely within our
scope
and is our duty to challenge that any
evidence and information whether that be
on viability or any other matter and
where appropriate to seek our own
external and independent advice and
where that advice
um
is not in Conformity with the
applicant's advice in the same way that
the court procedure rules require for
experts to meet and agree and understand
areas of of dispute as well as agreement
that's the process we would follow now
unless I'm going to be told otherwise by
either the head of planning policy or
Matthew I understand that how we word
this is in line with
how we are able to to put it in if you
will that's sort of in terms of you know
we can't go beyond that which is
reasonable but on a practical level with
individual applications you would indeed
have that kind of discussion if at all
possible or you would be seeking your
own advice so unless I mean if Mr
chairford or Mr Neal have anything to
add to that I think that it is for that
reason that we don't go as far as you're
suggesting uh in terms of
managing uh particularly viability
assessment advice you'd have to be
talking about it for all you couldn't
just do it for viability in my opinion
you'd have to say any external advice
rather than just viability assessments
because you then
ring fencing viability assessments as as
being treated in a different way to any
other kind of planning evidence and I'm
not sure we could make that fly uh and
perhaps again Mr Grafton might advise on
that
I don't think there's anything more for
me to say other than to agree with with
what you're saying I'm just looking to
care for to see whether he's got any
comments
I think I understand the point counselor
cattle is making but I think that has
been covered by what councilor Pemberton
has said in what Mr Grafton has said
come on
as you know from my background I've been
involved in many many many Barbados
assessments on behalf of businesses one
form or another
um and without exception on every
occasion appendix one to that report was
always the letter of instruction letter
of Engagement in terms of reference
um now I accept the point that we we
don't want to be involved in drafting
that
but
um it was disclosed to the reader of the
report what
the writer report had been asked to do
so as a fallback position like I'm
selling exactly where you're coming from
it's a fallback decision we should at
least see the terms of reference
um as part of that report otherwise
um you know
I can see Mr Butler shaking his head but
it is absolutely standard in 20 years of
my work it has always been done by not
only my firms I've worked for but every
other firm involved in financial
reporting that there has been a terms of
reference included I think your point is
well made councilor Kettle and noted so
a recommendation on page nine uh subject
to the discussion we've had and
potentially some changes in the word
Mr Grafton sorry you might I might be
preempting you here but it's just to
separate out those two those two
recommendations so the one the one
that's around um
recommendation to council that's about
part U maybe you deal with that one
first
sounds right so following Mr grafton's
advice uh the recommendation that the
Amendments depart you the SPD be
recommended to Stratford uneven District
Council for approval our members of
cabinet happy with that recommendation
and then the proposed amendments of to
part L of the SPD be formally consulted
upon are members of cabinet happy with
that recommendation great thank you
members of cabinet so moving on uh item
five Hampton Lucy neighborhood
development plan pre-submission
consultation responses uh once again
councilor Pemberton
thank you uh members of cabinets
um Hampton Lucy's neighborhood
development plan has reached uh the
point where
um we are now
um providing
um comments
um to uh the the draft plan as part of
the pre-consul pre-submission
consultation process
um uh first of all I'd like to thank
um I'll publicly thank members of the
Hampton Lucy NDP group for the work they
have done thus far in bringing their
neighborhood development plan to this to
this point and also to the policy team
specifically Matthew Neal for the work
that he's done
um members uh I this seems fairly
straightforward to me the we have our
schedule of comments and I'm really
seeking your confirmation that the
significant comments that appendix won't
be endorsed and submitted to Hampton
Lucy Parish Council as the formal
response to the pre-submission
consultation process in relation to the
draft NDP which is at appendix 2.
um any technical questions I will I will
defer to to Matthew as the previous item
but other than that seeking
recommendations thank you
councilor Harvey
I've commented upon ndps before and uh
suggested that it would be fitting that
those people who have done the donkey
work and put the years in to Preparing
an NDB are are acknowledged and to an
extent rewarded and I'm pleased to see
on the last page the acknowledgments
there are 10 names there of some willing
people who've supported their community
and done a lot of hard work good good
luck to them
thank you counselor Harvey I think at
this stage it is worth reminding us that
we are merely a consultant at this point
in time uh
councilor kettle
um I'm absolutely on side of the Council
of Harvey on this
um but what I would get I was going to
go one step further uh we've seen many
many neighborhood plans which as
casavius said everybody spends days
weeks months and many villages years
preparing
um
when this is signed off along with all
the others we will have quite a library
and my suggestion was that given there
are lots of other settlements
communities still developing their
neighborhood plans that we should
actually create an easily accessible
library because not only would it help
other villagers but also it provides a
really interesting
um picture of in this case Hampton Lucy
and that I don't know much about but
we've seen many many others and I think
that we should have available on public
record these neighborhood plans age to
thank those who prepared them that b to
make use of what is a very valuable
asset
thank you councilor Kettle I think
that's uh not a bad idea and I have to
say that when I read through some of the
neighborhood development plans uh what
really does strike me is the depth of
history and this particular area uh
and of course this plan will come back
uh later when we can thank the residents
for getting to that stage where it will
be submitted for approval meanwhile the
recommendation on page 37 the schedule
of significant comments and appendix
won't be endorsed and submitted to the
Hampton Lucy Parish Council as a formal
response to the pre-submission
consultation process associated with the
draft Hampton Lucy neighbor development
plan provided to appendix 2.
thank you members of cabinet so moving
on
we are now at uh councilor Harvey has
resources portfolio holder uh item six
capital budget monitoring councilor
Harvey
thank you
the purpose of this paper is to keep
members of the cabinet informed of the
progress made over the first five months
of the year in undertaking the council's
intended level of capital expenditure
this year
table two on page 48 demonstrates the
budgeted intention to undertake
expenditure of 15.1 million pounds this
year including section 106 projects
paragraph 1.4 indicates that the capital
expenditure of 5.2 million pounds has
already been undertaken by the end of
August in the first five months of the
year therefore the sums spent or
committed amount to 34 of this year's
available budget of 15.1 million pounds
appendix 2 on pages
59-63 provides summary information
concerning the various projects yet to
be funded through section 106 agreements
of the grand total of 8.3 million pounds
reported on page 62 some 7.3 million
pounds relates to the provision sorry
relates to funds identified for the
provision of affordable housing I asked
therefore leader that the
recommendations set out on page 47 that
the report in relation to the five-month
period to the end of August 2022 be
accepted
are there any questions have come in
from members of cabinet
councilor junid
and I just pick up again on something I
referred to earlier and that is the
tendency under section 106 and Silman is
to utilize sums away from the community
or the area that it was originally
um where the original sum arose as a
result of planning permission I
mentioned some other examples but I have
mentioned it before in at least two
occasions where
um sums that arose in Ulster as a result
of affordable housing for example
affordable housing on the Kenneth Farm
Road but also on the Ulster Hospital
site has ended up being going elsewhere
now I'm not averse to affordable housing
being going elsewhere because I actually
recognize that we are very very short of
affordable housing but given that Ulster
actually is they want their one
community that has the most problem with
the provision of affordable housing I'm
just wondering why we end up having this
money and going to support other
communities when we we can't support our
own particularly since some of this
money was actually put
um put to one side at a time which is no
longer the true at a time when the
garage sites in in on the Conway Estates
were available to have been bought for
the provision of affordable housing
um no longer the case but we are have a
real problem in Ulster with affordable
housing so I'm just saying that you know
beware of this tendency to try to to use
it elsewhere than the the community that
it arose from
councilor Pemberton uh thank you I think
I mean councilor Junior you're again
touching on
decisions made by individual planning
officers in relation to individual
planning applications and
I
um I've I and I've not seen quote a
tendency towards off-site contribution a
off-site contribution is not the first
Port of Call for this Authority and he's
only utilized when we have to use it
um so I think if there is any if there
is any concern that there's a tendency
towards and I might ask if you might
want to you might take that up with Mr
careford to ident to see if there is any
anything that indicates us some tenders
about certainly under my time as a
planning portfolio holder and from what
I'm seeing from a policy perspective I'm
not seeing any
um active or sort of unconscious
movement towards off-site contributions
I would also make the observation that
there are
other issues that preclude or mitigate
against additional
housing development of affordable or
Market in Ulster principally because of
how it's washed over by the green belt
and that does create challenges for us
and I think we have to find ways of of
mitigating that but I would perhaps
suggest that if you were to take that up
with Mr careford we might get some clap
we might get some clarity because I'm
it's not something that's that I think
and with deference to the new portfolio
holder on the development side I I we've
not sort of seen any indication of that
thank you councilor Pemberton Mr
Brooklyn I I just wanted to say that the
worst thing that we can possibly do is
give money back to developers when we've
received money in relation to affordable
housing please be clear I that's not
what I want and but I just wanted to
give a short answer so we do seek
Solutions within the parish but we do
have flexibility now that if we can't
find a solution in the parish so as not
to refund the the the the affordable
housing contribution we have got the
flexibility to apply that across the
piece and that that's what I have to say
I think losing funds would not be ideal
councilor Cargill thank you well all of
these are are valid arguments aren't
they I totally support uh casual Union
in this particular one because again I'm
seeing residents are saying why can't we
have more affordable housing and some of
the songs I appreciate are relatively
small perhaps couldn't build a number of
houses they can go to a scheme though
and top it up where you've got a number
of affordable houses so we get all of
that but it is seems occasionally it's a
one-way trip for this for this money and
I I don't agree that green belt issue
and also is a reason to say this money
should go elsewhere it's not it's not an
issue Greenbelt is a problem but it's
not the problem in this particular case
all right
I think the point that both councilor
Cargill and councilor June would have
made are noted meanwhile uh are there
any other questions or issues
in that case the recommendations on page
47 are members of capital cabinet happy
with those recommendations
thank you
so moving on Revenue budget monitoring
councilor Harvey
thank you leader I draw attention to the
revised piece of paper which has been
put around the table and I can see
Council cattle gluten already
said in the nicest possible way
the purpose of this report is to inform
the cabinet of the revenue picture of
the council's finances to the end of
August 2022 go back to vegan by asking
members to turn to appendix 3 on page
75. this shows that the net budget to be
financed by the council this year is
18.2 million pounds I use rounded
figures if we now turn to the revised
version that's just been circulated or
been laid on the table of appendix 2 on
page 73 we can see that the budget for
the whole year we can now see for the
budget for the whole year is for total
expenditure of 31.1 million pounds and
total income various sources of 14.7
million pounds the difference between
these two numbers together with the net
cost of the benefits of 232 000 pounds
represents the total amount to be funded
from various sources in other words
16.6 million pounds as set out in
appendix 2.
in the corresponding report last year
the council had received civil
contingencies funding from the
government of 13.6 million pounds of
which 12.9 million pounds had been
distributed in ways consistent with the
government's intentions The Marked
reduction 12 months later in the need
for further financing concerning
covid-19 outbreak is demonstrated by the
net expenditure to the end of period
five of only 45
000 pounds set against the funds
available for the year as a whole set
out in the lower table of appendix 2.
turning to the position at the end of
period five we can see that from
appendix 2 that in round terms the
council's expenditure of 14.2 million
pounds was 495 000 pounds more than
budgeted
this reflects a variety of reasons set
out in paragraph 3.1 both positive and
negative in relation to each head of
service
combination of these results means that
the net cost of services provided in the
first five months of the year excluding
the net cost of benefits of a hundred
and fifty three thousand pounds was six
million pounds 709
000 pounds less than had been budgeted
section three and five of the paper
identify the principal items of variance
from their budgeted figures During the
period April to August due to a
combination of both favorable and
unfavorable Reasons by the service
category and by their type of income and
expenditure section 4 however provides a
projection of the likely outturn for the
year as a whole based on results to date
and projections informed by current
information and estimates based on the
experience of heads of service
the out turn for the year as a whole is
shown in appendix one and is anticipated
to be a favorable outturn of 126 000
pounds
section six of the paper demonstrates
that on the basis of present
expectations for the current year the
council's reserve Position will be
reduced at the end of 2022-23 by 775
000 pounds from 8.5 million pounds to
7.7 million pounds in addition the
council's current earmarked reserves
stand at 10.4 million pounds as
identified in appendix 4.
before concluding I'd like to draw
attention to paragraph 2.3
the time of the 2023 sorry at the time
of the 2022-23 budget was set the rate
of inflation for the current calendar
year was anticipated by the bank of
England to Peak at four percent before
declining
times have changed inflation is now in
double figures due to a variety of
factors interest rates have been
increased in recent months to begin to
address domestic inflationary pressures
and as a consequence of the government's
recent fiscal event proposals interest
rates will predictably increase further
both this year and next with evident
consequences for the council's finances
for the time being and due to some
prudent decisions we've taken in recent
months the council's finance can bear
the strain for this financial year but
the uncertainty currently prevailing in
financial markets in government
intentions over economic policy and its
consequences for its capacity and
willingness to adequately Finance local
Authority means that this year's budget
setting process will be challenging
very challenging
finally subject to any questions could I
have agreement with members of cabinet
for the write-off of the six sums of
money identified in paragraph 2.4 please
unless there are any other points of
information that Mr burrow might wish to
provide or any questions from Members
um may I ask that the report be received
council's unit
um two questions if I might uh one is
that the the
um considerable cost of our Waste
Services is a is a resource issue uh I'm
just wondering whether it would be
useful to invite vitha to speak to all
counselors as a as a as you know at some
point it's a suggestion
um because I think all counselors might
appreciate a hearing
um what their issues are and whether or
not it's likely to because I'm thinking
penalty charges it might be useful to
know just what their thinking is
um so that's on one resource issue but
the second one is on the on costs and
inflation
um I I agree about the costs of
inflation and in fact it was actually
said uh Steve freyr I don't know if you
remember Steve freyr who used to be the
um and uh who used to be the head of uh
fanax at Warwickshire County Council
he's now chair of the public sector
appointments audit appointments and he's
saying the audit for local councils is
going to rise by 150 percent uh this
next year that's that's just one
indication of just what is going to
happen this next year with inflation
thank you councilor junid uh I think um
they do look very carefully at whether
biffers should talk to councilors
because at the end of the day it is a
contract and it is managed by officers
the points about inflation are
absolutely right inflation is going to
be a real problem in the coming year
meanwhile the recommendations on page 65
sorry counselor kettle
thank you Mr chairman
um
thank you for the update of appendix 2.
it's a little throws a little bit more
light on on what's going on
um
the
if I'd like to look at the income sign
first where we have got an encouraging
1.2 million surplus here to date
um but the bigger figure in that
is recharges to other accounts of 667
000.
um
being 800 actual 870 compared to
budgeted of 202. And yet when I look at
the papers
despite that being the largest variance
of any variance uh sorry forgive me
government benefit uh housing benefits
is actually being a variance
um but we we understand that is
completely uncontrollable
but of the controllable income and
expenditure we've got no explanation of
what that 667 is
um
and we have had this before I think it
is really important where you've got big
figures being different to budget that
we have an understanding of what the
reason for that change is
um it is a positive but it you know that
is half the positive variance
um I'd then like to go on to the
expenditure Society and this is a bit of
a challenge what I again suggest are
is
um
some of us
um we'll remember working in
inflationary times
where
cost overruns
could easily be attributed to inflation
but they can also as historically has
been the case been attributed to a
genuine cost overruns which are not
inflationary
and therefore what I have seen going
back to my professional experience some
20 25 years ago
that if you're reporting to uh or on on
financial performance
you'd actually carve out what is an
inflationary increase
and what is a cost
uh as a little difficult to describe it
but I'm going to say cost overrun uh for
whatever reason and I think that is
really important that we have an
understanding now understanding now
hopefully uh when we get through to the
anniversary of the very significant cost
increases we may be lucky enough to see
inflation falling but until we do see
inflation falling
it is very very helpful to understand
what the inflationary impact is on our
budget as opposed to our
expenditure difference
I think you make a very interesting
point councilor Kettle and I'm sure it's
one that will be taken on board
councilor Harvey do you wish to respond
on cancer kettle's first point of the
explanation for six six seven four five
six I think that's a question for Mr
Burrell Mike no more than I do
Mr Barrow
I haven't anything that's what it could
be again it's it's something that's been
brought up before and we should comment
on it I believe it's where we're
bringing income in from earmark reserves
but I will clarify that with it with a
further client back to uh cancer Council
and if I could just address those other
points about the inflation the way we
normally address inflation is we hold a
central inflation pass and when the
inflation for each contract or whatever
is calculated we then apply the budget
from that central part to that area so
that effectively covers the inflation so
if there's any additional overruns in
car stitch it then shows itself so it's
not masked by inflation itself
we know what um the refuse contract is
going to go up by because we have that
information within the contract we will
be applying that budget to that service
area and if it overspends beyond that it
will be a service over on cost rather
than an inflation cost
you will let us know what the 667 was
for them please Mr Burrell I certainly
will yeah
um
thank you for that explanation on the
inflation issue
I think that what that is telling me
is that these figures do not include
inflation because actually the
additional overspend due to inflation is
coming out of a reserve
and therefore these that half a million
cost is real overspend
um which to me five months in
um is
a little bit worrying
um
what is what is the real position in
real pounds and pennies what are we
actually spending above budget
um it doesn't matter which Port we're
coming out of it
um if we are subsidizing the figures
here out of uh and reserve and inflation
of itself and I understand why we have
inflation Reserve but if we are
effectively subsidizing these figures by
the the inflationary element being
charged elsewhere I think we should see
how much that is so that we can have an
understanding what inflation has cost us
in the five months today
do you wish to respond to that at all Mr
Bill
I think the paragraph 2.3 I tried to
sort of put in there that as of today
where we're still working through some
of the contracted figures for well to
calculate the inflation amount uh
inflation hasn't fully hit us yet uh the
salaries award hasn't been
finalized and applied
the energy costs haven't found their way
through entire accounts yet because they
go up from October
and most of our contracts start to
increase from this month
so those pressures will be coming coming
forward and just just to go back to your
other
comment about this 600 and the overspend
on the top I will clarify what's within
that 600 but I think you'll find some
money's being bought in from here Mark
reserves and then being paid out at the
top so it does look as though it's
overspended but it's money coming in the
bottom thing being paid out from a
landmark Reserve but I will clarify that
thank you you made some very interesting
points there Mr burrow not least that
inflation will start hitting us from now
on councilor Harvey
along that line the biggest single cost
is employee cost and I can't imagine
that there is any single cost that is
more acutely understood and and closely
managed than employment costs
councilor shenton
just a a common thank you leader um the
just to go back to what parents of the
junior was saying about bitter I
fundamentally disagree with uh any uh
reason or any point in bringing biffer
before counselors I don't think that
will serve us well I don't think it's
necessary we need to let the officers
get on with the job I think we could do
more harm than good in any negotiations
over possible penalties
thank you councilor shenton with that
the recommendations on page 65 are we
happy with the recommendations members
of cabinet
agreed thank you members of cabinet so
item C issues arising from overview and
scrutiny councilor Crum
thank you Mr chairman um
obviously the osc went on for a good
while probably slightly longer in
cabinet meetings ago
um so it was a
a very good meeting
um
the main constant is three areas I'll be
talking about one is the one two three
secondly is BD UK and broadband and the
third is the Tuscan finish group
regarding the the merger and the lessons
learned
so those those three
um Julie Lewis did an excellent
presentation which went through some of
the positives
around the uh the one two three
um particularly through again collected
weekly
um lots of people reporting they've been
you've grabbing only been half full
after three weeks the app has really
gone done well I think the app has could
say lots of residents are happy with the
app cancel the Harvey
um sorry that's the one
um I do apologize and there was high
praise for Julie Lewis and Craig born in
particular as well as a contact center
star Avery led by Mr Platts there
get that one in Mr Platts after after
Friday
um
yeah so I think one thing that did come
out was the communication needs to be
reinforced and repeated regarding the
reasons for doing this because some um
accounts that Ralph did a survey were 18
out of a hundred residents who contacted
her that weren't using the green um the
candy
and that tied in with the 82 percent who
were actually using it of the 131 000 so
obviously counts the roll survey
mirrored the council Council District so
that's very impressive so
um so the bits about the presentation
which said that um the three weekly
residual saves a hundred and three
thousand pound Mars Branham a quite sort
of a circuit
2650 tons of CO2 which is equivalent of
66 Asian now the events 101 168 great
white sharks or 10 Andy crumps after
he's had had his team so
um so I think we need to get that
message over and be reinforced to ensure
we get uh rights up again and again
there was quite a few learning points
um particularly around assisted
collections
um being missed uh flats and Bin stores
were a particular problem
um and
um the contractor not necessarily doing
saying doing what they said
um
another bit was communication
um especially to local members
particularly around delivery that could
have been improved although most members
are extremely helpful and using local
knowledge and created Miss bins one or
two uh the feedback from the officers
was they sometimes hindered the prop
process so mine it's a learning thing
for all of us really so um so that was
quite positive
um the other thing I'm being really
quick now SDC officers did provide a
very thorough and accurate account of
how they manage biffer and how they are
done to account so I think that allows
some of the fears of bringing
um bring them in to speak directly to
members because the officers did an
excellent presentation
so regarding the one two three one of
the things that came out was that osc
requests that cabinet look at sdc's
charging policy around extra bins for
residents with medical conditions that
generated additional waste and also
regarding parents with several young
children who are in nappies but
obviously osc appreciated that there
were budgetary implications of doing so
so that's one two three done quite
quickly
bduk came in and spoke about the
challenges of reaching rural rarely as
locations and remote properties were
full fiber and one property for examples
coaches have been 100k
so obviously that's not feasible other
options will need to be looked at four
or five G and mobile broadband and and
to create a Community member not too far
from me
um the low hanging fruit had already
gone and it appeared to be a case the
diminishing returns in terms of cost so
we need to be creative how we actually
get some
um the bduk to to engage and again size
and presentations
um will be sent to all members and very
quickly now the RSC Tusk and finish
group The merger lessons that review met
on the 29th of September which I
reported back to on the 30th to RSC the
terms of reference of group were agreed
and the scope and document noted an LGA
recommended organization was appointed
to provide support and an independent
overview to the group and the LGA were
providing significant funding for this
organization to do so
so a quick run through
um yeah and one one can one point to
note was the charging policy
you can counselor Crump
Council of unit
as um Vice chair I was very grateful for
the chair of the ovun scrutiny committee
to allow counselors to submit uh their
particular experiences and I think there
were six letters came in six emails came
into the chair
um about the problems with the Bin's
collections which I think were hopefully
fed into into the officer and fed into
that
um I've had another one since
um today actually where one area of 11
houses have had no collection at all
since the contract began so at the ovary
in scrutiny did a good job of asking
those questions but there's obviously
some more to be asked
I I hope those 11 houses have been
reported through the system canceled
unit right can I say they've been
regularly written by every single one of
those residents has reported them and
the district council has reported them
and now the dip Parish Council clerk has
reported it
I'm sure that is something our officers
will take up very robustly with biffer
so thank you so moving on to the unblock
items
Council kettle
um I don't know how long I've heard BD
UK say they're moving forward I'm
encouraged that the chairman was
probably in the room with them
um I suspect uh those rural Awards which
many of us represent will still be
dreaming about having an adequate
Broadband facility uh when our
grandchildren or great-grandchildren
will be living there because quite
frankly there has been no change since I
joined this Council I've just had BD uh
BD UK repeatedly saying things are
moving forward they are not
thank you counselor cattle
right they unblock items cabinet work
program climate change panel markets
Forum these are on block items nobody's
raised any issues that need to be
discussed
I've had no urgent business uh I would
like members of cabinet to know that the
next meeting will be exceedingly short
because they're meeting on the 31st of
October is canceled the next meeting is
Monday the 28th of November so thank you
everyone meeting closed